[Musique]
c'est avec vous Cyril Payet aujourd'hui
bonjour Cyril on reporter ici à la
rédaction de France 24 Cyril on vient de
de faire le bilan et le constat de ce
qui s'est passé d'un côté de l'autre en
Russie et à qui avec Gulliver crack on
est face à des attaques de drone des
frappes des riposte est-ce qu'on efface
un changement de paradigme dans cette
guerre en tout cas ce qui est un
contestable c'est qu'effectivement on
voit une nette accélération puis un
changement effectivement de ce logiciel
du conflit avec des frappes maintenant
civils tout ça avec les éléments de
langage qui laisse entendre qu'il y aura
une contre-offensive on y reviendra de
de Kiev ça depuis des semaines ou des
mois ce qui est peu un peu inquiété en
tout cas c'était un petit peu la
tonalité de du de l'intervention de que
les vers crack c'est que ça peut
effectivement inquiéter si on rentre
dans une logique de cette fameuse loi du
talion là si profité du crime et de la
peine c'est pas une méthode très très
nouvelle et très bonne puisque elle date
de royaume de BA et en général ça ne
peut que en venimer les choses mais en
tout cas ça fait suite ou ça ferait
suite à une accélération sur le terrain
d'attaque au drone sur des cibles des
attaques de jour
il y a 24 heures qui font extrêmement
peur à la population et ça pourrait
effectivement être cette fameuse loi du
talion et bien un oeil pour eux nous
renvoyons des drones à 1000 km puisqu'on
est à 1000 km de Kiev à Moscou donc
c'était pas facile à atteindre et alors
donc évidemment Moscou pointe du doigt
Kiev Kiev comme ça a été évidemment dit
avant moi très habilement dit c'est pas
nous mais on peut peut-être être on
n'est pas contre en tout cas mais il y a
aussi énormément de narratifs de contre
un narratif parce qu'on le sait depuis
de nombreux mois aussi on y a une guerre
informationnelle que ce livre Les les
deux camps l'un d'ailleurs n'est pas
meilleur ou moins bon que l'autre et du
côté de des réseaux sociaux pardon qui
font qui fleurissent sur le net en
Ukraine on rappelle la montée en
puissance de Vladimir Poutine et
l'attentat pro enfin qui était attribué
au tché en 99 300 morts en plein Moscou
qui avaient permis de renforcer la
politique sécurité et l'avènement de
Vladimir Poutine donc tout est tout est
possible la thèse des partisans internes
sur le mode d'un peu de l'attaque de
Belgorod qui avait fait énormément glosé
et parler il fait beaucoup de mal à la
Russie il faut le dire et quand même
souvent retenu mais effectivement pour
répondre à votre question on a
définitivement changé de paradigme dans
une guerre maintenant presque une guerre
de drone interposée et maintenant on l'a
vu à Kiev tout le monde attend la
prochaine réplique qui viendrait de
l'état-major russe et tout cela
s'inscrit dans le cadre de cette
contre-offensive qu'on dit annoncé par
Kiev mais qui en réalité a déjà commencé
effectivement je vais citer Sunzu l'art
de la guerre attaque tournée quand il
n'est pas préparé apparaît quand tu n'es
pas attendu et ça se résume c'est vieux
comme comme l'Antiquité mais on peut
penser que cette idée de quand on
foncier est un mode d'affaiblissement
général du moral muscovie du Moral russe
mais aussi militaire et puis c'est une
forme de d'affaiblissement sur cette
longue bande de frontières 1300 km qui
séparent la Russie et l'Ukraine et on
l'a vu avec l'événement de de Belgorod
qui était totalement inédit inattendu et
maintenant qui va évidemment donner
beaucoup de surfroies d'aller ta major
russe donc c'est peut-être ça la réponse
est-ce que cette contrefensive qu'on
attend et qui est très risqué parce
qu'il y a un aide massif maintenant
occidental on le sait c'est un peu bas
les masques dans cette affaire
l'Occident va aider volumes Zelinski
alors si on fait une contre-offensive et
qu'on perd le dommage sera énorme alors
peut-être qu'on peut avancer un peu
masqué et peut-être beaucoup de gens
disent que cette contre-offensive en
fait ne se déclara jamais par contre
elle avait les biens déjà commencé c'est
ce qu'on va en ce moment peut-être de
manière plus discrète merci beaucoup
pour ces éléments de compréhension